so explain to everyone what trauma is
before we get kind of more into how you
actually run the business you say it's
the future of work right which is this
big bold claim how exactly are you doing
it yeah so we're a labor marketplace and
we specialize in connecting workers with
open shifts at distribution centers and
event venues and these categories
specifically we chose because
both of them have variable needs for
labor so i actually used to work in a
distribution center we sold engineering
parts uh i was part of a management
rotation program there i initially went
into finance and then got that job and i
just wanted to learn how to manage
people
um
and one of our main clients was spacex
so if you think about it spacex is like
okay we're going to build a rocket we
need to buy a bunch of product from this
supplier so then what happens at the
supplier is you have your full-time
workforce you have all this new product
that you're about to ship so the
warehouse gets crazy busy for about two
to three months until the purchase
order's over
so what they do is they and what i did
is i would go over to my computer and i
would email all these staffing offices
so there's a 520 billion dollar industry
called the staffing market it's two
percent of america's workforce and that
is like temp labor but the experience is
totally broken so i would have to wait
weeks in advance until people were able
to show up if i were to order say i'm
like okay i'm gonna ask for a hundred
people
less than half would show up and this is
consistent across the staffing industry
and then once they arrived i couldn't
give any credit like to the good people
or like say oh i actually don't want to
work with this worker again they didn't
really do that well of a job so there's
so much opportunity to revolutionize
this through tech and we're leaning into
that so when you think about uh the
distribution centers and the event
venues uh essentially you have a
software platform where an individual
can go on and say hey i want to drive
for uber today i want to do food
delivery or i want to go work with traba
and you're really competing for kind of
this gig worker uh in the beginning at
least and what they're able to do from
my understanding is go to either the
distribution center or to the event
venue but you all do a lot of work to
make sure that it's not just some random
person off of the street it meets some
quality bar it has some skill set um in
terms of the service you're able to
deliver talk a little bit about uh again
being upfront with the folks who are on
the platform and making sure that they
meet that quality bar like how do you
filter who is good for the platform
versus maybe hey this person isn't gonna
actually uh make us look good to our
customers yeah so we actually have uh we
have a very high bar for quality so just
like how trauba hires the top point zero
zero one percent of engineers operators
designers same with we wanna provide
that to our business customers and there
are a lot of workers out there that
wanna work they're working hard
we specialize in light industrial so
example shifts are setting up a stage
for a large concert putting boxes onto
trucks things that anyone can do they
just have to show up on time and have a
good work ethic so because of that we do
hold our quality hold the workers to a
high standard there's background checks
we get to know the workers there's an
onboarding process through our app and
then with good behavior work businesses
will favor the best workers and then
those workers get first dibs on next
shifts on on future shifts um
and and what's interesting is actually
it's a lot bigger of a pie than just the
gig worker marketplace so we provide
transparency upfront pricing like they
know exactly how much they're going to
get our minimum wage on the platform is
13 an hour which is well beyond a lot of
like most states minimum wage um and
business customers are happy to pay it
because of the of the
uh the best workers and being able to
get them flexibly so you started in
miami you're now starting to go kind of
city by city which for most people
they'd be like why do you do that uh you
have a specific experience uh in your
background of having worked at uber uh
and kind of seeing how that business
went city by city and launched talk a
little bit about uh kind of the strategy
of starting in one city really focusing
and kind of perfecting the model and
then choosing to go ahead and start
scaling at city by city yeah so uh
thanks for mentioning that i joined uber
right when uber eats was first launching
got the opportunity to build out certain
operational processes it was very much
hustle at that moment we were delivering
ipads to restaurants calling restaurants
to tell them that they had an order on
their ipad if they weren't weren't
getting it um
setting up their menus on the back end
just very manual stuff but then with the
growth of the business it unlocked an
awesome opportunity for me to
essentially get this like
entrepreneurship mba like global mba
where uber was like okay we're gonna
launch mexico city we're gonna launch
sao paulo we're gonna go to south korea
like there's not that many people here
but you've been here you've been doing
it so you get this awesome opportunity
to expand the product
um and we're we have that opportunity
now at trava so we've built something
that the customers love we're growing
extremely fast in miami so we're going
to be having like a lot of more presence
across the country and globally and
anyone that wants to work at trouba can
essentially get that opportunity if they
join and are in the right place how do
you pick what city to go to next is
there like a process that you go through
that you're like okay this is the
framework for evaluation yeah so a
couple things one it's interesting
because workers that aren't in miami or
not and aren't in florida are actually
downloading our app wanting to sign up
work at trava so that's one contributor
we're like okay wow and in texas we have
a lot of workers that are already on the
platform there's not even any shifts yet
um and then another is our business
customers so we've actually had
most of our uh there's a proportion of
our business customers in miami that are
like hey this as soon as you open up in
houston like we want to use trava troba
has like been able to service us really
well here so one is like being pulled by
our customers and the other is just
broader market so
in terms of the light industrial
landscape it's a 40 billion dollar
staffing industry
florida is a two billion dollar industry
uh texas is 6.4 billion so we do want to
go after large markets uh and really
dominate there so we talked a little bit
about kind of making sure that you have
the highest quality users on the
platform which is part of the service
that you offer to your customer um
you've also mentioned hiring kind of the
top .001 percent of uh various um skill
sets for uh the employees of the
business how does running a business
with kind of a plus players differ from
maybe running a company that has you
know a minus or b plus or even c you
know uh grade players like what changes
or how is it different from you as a ceo
actually running the business yeah so
it's something that you notice when it
happens but but like when you're growing
and you're like oh i just need to hire
somebody
you're overlooking at like the
opportunity cost there so someone is
taking responsibility amongst themselves
and if they're an a plus top one percent
uh one of the smartest people they're
just going to be
optimizing and innovating in ways that
the other person would have not done so
there actually is tangible example of
that so actually yesterday we had all
hands and somebody on my team was
presenting this really cool product that
they built that essentially slots in
workers based on prioritization so
initially we started we only started the
company 11 months ago so we were doing a
lot of things that don't scale we would
call our customers we would like really
like manually go into google sheets and
say okay these these workers should go
go to these shifts and he built this
entire back end that essentially just
automates like requests based on certain
behaviors that they've had initially and
if we had just been like oh you know
what we're just going to have someone
that has like call center experience to
own this project
uh we've seen firsthand how that makes a
difference and then
secondarily to that people will pull in
their friends so if you hire a plus
players that like vinod khosla has said
like the team you build is the company
you build and i've seen it firsthand as
you get bigger and bigger as a ceo
you're kind of having to delegate almost
like a lot more than being in the
trenches like looking at everything and
knowing that an a plus player is
thinking through it is really awesome
when you run the all hands like talk to
other founders but like what do you do
at your all hands meetings that you're
like this is really really helpful and
helps our business move forward yeah so
the the purpose of an all hands is to
make sure that everyone of the company
is aligned as to where the ship is
heading so we've been very intentional
with our priorities right now our growth
healthy unit economics and a 10x
customer experience
everyone at the company is is aligned on
those priorities and working towards
them
um so so in all hands what we'll do is
initially when we first started the
company we were all just in a conference
room every morning we had an all hands
and we just talked about what we're
doing uh now it's more intentional so
people will
write in projects that they're working
on that they think that the rest of the
company would benefit from learning
about and then people will upvote
different projects that we want to be
shared and then we do look at our kpis
we're very rigorous at looking at our
metrics every week because if you're not
paying attention to them they're just
not going to get better so we set very
ambitious targets and we just try to
keep that momentum in velocity and
nothing's off the table it's like we're
going to get there and it's going to be
actually this has happened multiple
times where we're like we need to ship
this business product by november 1st it
was last year we were like and the
engineers were like oh my gosh it's like
insane time frame but then we're like we
can do it let's just like think of ways
we can prioritize this and get it right
we hustled and we made it happen and
like our investors saw it like all these
little data points
convinced our investors that trava when
they say they're going to do something
they're going to win and they're going
to do it well yeah
when you think of these really ambitious
goals and you're so obsessive about the
metrics themselves talk me through like
how often do you guys review the metrics
and then how do you communicate those
metrics or progress towards these goals
with the rest of the team is this like a
weekly email that goes out do you have
weekly meetings what is like the
operational kind of tempo around metrics
and goals inside the company yeah great
question so
basically as you scale every sub team
needs to have metrics like sub kpis that
lead up to the main kpis of the company
so we mentioned growth so gross booking
so like how much revenue is coming into
the business is an important metric that
we track just as a company but there's a
lot of inputs that go into that so like
how many new businesses join the
platform how many shifts per business
are happening you can essentially just
break it down into a formula that every
sub team can get really focused on uh so
on the workers for example uh how many
perfect shifts like we do track fill
rate so what i mentioned in the staffing
industry they can only fill half half of
what you ask for less than half trouba
feels 100 so that 100 fill rate is like
a 10x customer experience it's like oh
my gosh i asked for 15 i actually like
over over asked because i was expecting
you only to deliver 10 like now i have
15 people here um so that's kind of what
we do so in the all hands we we go over
the overarching kpis or we also zoom in
on any kpis that need fixing um
and then every sub team is tracking a
kpi so they can really innovate and just
be like look as long as my number's
moving up like i can use my imagination
on this uh you talked about in the
beginning of the business you guys were
all in the same conference room uh you
also are somewhat unique in that there's
no remote work there's no uh hey maybe
you want to go take the afternoon off
and uh you know go hang out by the pool
or anything like that it's in a person
in an office uh for a very long period
of time every single day why do you
emphasize so much the in-person versus
remote work yeah so we hire for people
that we really believe that they're
going to be on the new york stock
exchange like
ringing the bell with us everyone that
joins now we have a growth mindset which
is one of our values
everyone that joins now has the
opportunity to grow into a leadership
like a very high up leadership position
as at the company
if someone is doing well at their job no
one's ever gonna say you know what you
can't take that on there's many examples
of a lot of startups that have done this
and then they become like there's this
woman at uber named austin austin guy
she joined as an intern and then she led
the autonomous vehicle project and she
was at the new york stock exchange like
ringing the bell there's lots of
examples of people that join early are
with the team in person
get to know the culture of the company
uh
so with that growth mindset one thing i
wanted to mention is there's like this
component to having a company that's a
little bit more than just a
transactional i'm doing my project it's
like this camaraderie and like really
stark belief in the mission of the
company in like the trajectory of the
company and you really only get that in
person and remote companies know this
which is why they do off-sites like if
they really believed that you could
build an awesome company with a lot of
loyalty a lot of
the employees really understanding each
other and liking each other they would
not do offsites if they if they knew
they could be all done or remote and
then the second is communication so like
you're really slowing down your company
if you're like okay let's hop on this
zoom call and then you're like okay 30
minutes is the zoom call so here we are
talking at traba we're all sitting next
to each other so i'm the ceo i sit next
to i have the cto there's all the
engineers all the operators everyone's
in the same room so they'll just kind of
pick up just by osmosis what's going on
which actually allows them to innovate
better because maybe it wouldn't have
been worth either of our time to hop on
a 30 minute zoom meeting but when i get
back from an investor meeting i'm like
guys this is what i learned this is how
it went this is how we're thinking about
things what do you guys think and all
these conversations just happen
sporadically
so i feel like or i've seen with my own
eyes just like the intangibles of
working together in person it's just
been really good you mentioned growth
mindset what are the other values that
you guys really kind of instill as hey
this is what we stand for yeah so the
first is dream big it goes back to what
i mentioned about being intentional we
don't shy away from saying that look
we're going to do this we're going to do
it right we're going to aim to be a
trillion dollar business like our
investors they only invest in the best
companies in the world they've seen with
their own eyes the the facts of what we
what we've been able to deliver they see
the market size uh
so if we're work so dream big is the
first uh trillion dollar business not
off the table and then olympians work
ethic it takes some hustle to do that
growth mindset so i've never been a ceo
of a 22 person company it's growing and
growing so i need to have a growth
mindset to be reflective of how can i
get better i want everyone on the team
to also feel that way because their
career is also going to skyrocket um and
then the last one is customer obsession
so we're building for a customer that
has been overlooked a lot of people in
silicon valley haven't met the working
class of our country so these people get
up early they get on the bus they go to
the warehouse they work their butts off
all day they actually ask us to do a
second job like they're hustlers so
we're hustling for them we're really
we're really obsessed about making their
lives better talk to me about the
investors that you work with on a
day-to-day basis you've got some of the
best investors in the world that have
invested in the business uh and you said
previously to me that like it's kind of
like getting this entrepreneurship mba
because you're getting to learn directly
from them what is that experience like
yeah it's been an absolute like it's
just been an amazing experience so our
investors are founders fund uh keith
raboy who's here with us in miami he
throws workout classes for the team he
introduced us to brian chesky brian
chesky was like look like this guy is
really the best in the world because at
that time i was about to to raise our
series a and like he gave really good
advice so like just
uh he's always checking in he's coming
by the office like asking people what
they're working on giving people his
opinion uh the other investor is
katherine boyle who invested from
general catalyst she's now to andrews
and horowitz she's also here in miami so
being in person has also us being one of
the the few tech companies that are
fully in person all in miami has really
opened up a lot more access than if we
were remote or if we were just in san
francisco where were a diamond doesn't
it it's just been like a really cool
game changer yeah and when you think
about um you know these investors how
much of it is uh in a conversation like
hey let me tell you exactly what i think
you should do and it's prescriptive
versus it's let me introduce you to four
or five people who have been in the same
situation and go learn almost through
osmosis or learn from kind of the
history of what they've gone through
like how do you
interact with them in terms of actually
getting advice and then which do you
find more valuable
we actually get both so for the second
point uh one thing we're trying to
tackle right now is how do we really
build our business side of the
marketplace with extreme scale because
now that we've actually got quite a
quite a variety of customers we're
trying to build out like more of a sales
team so if you're an a plus sales person
definitely apply to travel there's lots
of opportunity to get in early but keith
was like look i'm gonna i'm gonna
introduce you to one of the first people
at fair first people at uh doordash and
i got to learn as okay what doordash
just like trava and just like uber eats
like you were early at the early days
you were calling in to restaurants
trying to make things hack things
together and then they also were like
okay how do we change this from
founder-led sales to now more of a
structured sales sales process so he
will like our investors will connect us
to other people but then they're also
very much in the trenches with us and
then it's just more conversational so if
it's something that's just like hey i
just want to get your thoughts on this
this is how we're thinking about it
we've got we've gotten a lot of great
advice one of the things that you
mentioned is uh keith throws workout
parties i've seen the team multiple
times you guys go to berries and
have this kind of fitness culture where
does that come from is that something
that just as you and you're interested
in fitness and the rest of the team kind
of uh jumps in as well or is there
something intentional there from a
company building standpoint it's
actually interesting it wasn't actually
that intentional it was more of but i
did think i do think it comes from the
olympians work ethic so a lot of
athletes they have to put in the work
like the results speak for themselves
they know that practice makes perfect so
us being intentional about that value
just brought a lot of athletes we have
some like duke tennis tennis players on
the team we've gotten an nfl player that
wanted to to work at trouba he actually
went to uva with me um and then uh keith
is very interested and since keith is
very much involved in our process and
our our company he'll he'll throw
barry's classes and we'll just all work
out together and then secondarily to
that we're all trying to have a healthy
mind healthy body like it all kind of
compounds we're not sitting there like
hunched over at our desks just working
on things and not like thinking being
intentional about it's the long term so
uh we have like protein at the office we
we buy like breakfast lunch and dinner
for everybody they can put in their
orders we have this catering company
that does it is actually like if you
like working in person and you want to
be
kind of like that entrepreneurship mba
situation where you're working with
these people that have literally been
early at some of the best companies in
the world um and build really cool stuff
like we're the company to do it at so
yeah uh you mentioned the meals um this
is more like meal plans this is not like
just meal plans like hey randomly let's
order from mcdonald's talk a little bit
about what the meal situation is so that
also came organic so we initially we
worked out of the founders fund office
initially which was really cool like
right when we started the company uh it
was last summer so everyone had already
been vaccinated everyone was starting to
work in person we were like you know
what and founders fund was look we have
this office in brickell we have space if
you guys want to start working in the
office with us who immediately unlocked
we got like an office manager snacks and
like initially they were paying for
doordash every day so we were like okay
this is great then we moved to our own
office we we started with doordash but
by that point most people the company
what just to walk you through like kind
of like how it works is like people show
up to work we'll grind together around 6
p.m like of course people are like
starting to like okay like i'm gonna go
hit the gym so actually almost everyone
at the company if people rather do yoga
or like some people go take a nap
because people live close to the office
they go do their own thing for like an
hour and a half hour so then get back to
work and then they're just like
refreshed and ready to grind again so
that's actually like started to become a
thing so when we were thinking about
meal plans or how we were going to do
our meals people were starting to be
like oh like to be honest like i get
kind of groggy when i have like these
arepas like every single day and like
all these like all this door that stuff
so we were like let's look into catered
fit so we actually use this one meal
plan service called cater fit people can
say okay i'm paleo i'm vegan i'm uh keto
and it's really cool they just like
design a meal plan we have these
refrigerators in the office and it's and
they deliver the food every morning so
it's it's really cool so if you're
trying to optimize for like being on the
top top of your game for health and uh
like learning it's it's an awesome place
talk to me about um you have this very
specific culture and you're looking for
a plus players that want to work hard go
after a large problem and if you are
successful it will be this massive
opportunity obviously the people who are
early to it will uh financially benefit
but also you'll have this you know
amazing impact for millions and millions
of people in the united states and and
globally uh what are some of the
mistakes you've made from like a hiring
standpoint what are some of the lessons
that you've learned as you've gotten
this like entrepreneurship mba where
you're like man i wish that i knew that
in the beginning but you know better to
learn now than when we're a thousand
employees or 5 000 employees yeah so
actually it we did initially hire
for
the role like that is currently there so
we were like okay we need to build
relationships with workers let's just
hire anyone that can like build that
relationship it just didn't work out
because what you need to do is hire for
six months a year out so you hire top
caliber people
initially they may end up doing the
small stuff like the hustle and that's
actually going to make them better at
their jobs when we scale and they
understand like oh i did that myself so
even at ubereats like i myself like
loaded a ton of ipads in my car and was
driving around hot texas like talking to
restaurant owners but what that did is
it gave me insights for when we were
building a restaurant onboarding process
at scale i was like oh actually this is
like the nuances of how it works uh so
that's that's one lesson we did learn
about
about that and then the second is like
being extremely upfront about what it
takes and it's it's fine if it's not for
you so like a lot of companies they'll
like try to wind and down candidates
kind of mislead them into thinking that
like working is going to be a certain
way
uh but then when someone joins they're
like wait a minute like this is not what
i expected and that never works out you
just want to be like look we the company
is operating this way
uh eventually at scale we'll have such a
moot will be such a big business that
will probably have a little bit more
work-life balance but if you want to
join a series a or seed company and you
actually want that company to be
successful and win like there's just
going to be a lot going on in your
profession that maybe you're gonna have
to make some sacrifices in your personal
life when you think about uh the culture
that you all have cultivated uh when you
have eight plus players uh i always
equate no [ __ ] with a plus players
right they're here to do the job uh
there's not um i joke with friends like
there's not a lot of chit chat it's just
like hey we're here to work um and
obviously if everyone has that same
mindset because of the filtering that
goes on before they actually come to the
company uh they feel like i am
surrounded by great people um and it's
very similar to like maybe like the navy
seals or or some of these high
performance teams uh you know that
aren't in business where people almost
feel like imposter syndrome to a degree
because like i can't believe i get to
work with these people every day and i
have to bring 100 of my best effort or i
will be exposed that i'm not as good as
everybody else um and so naturally that
also leads to honesty so the no [ __ ]
no chit chat but it also leads to this
like honesty component where uh feedback
nobody takes it personally or is a much
less personal kind of uh offense taken
when somebody says hey you're not doing
what we need you to do step it up and so
what do you see there in terms of like
the conversations that employees have
with each other um and kind of the
culture that naturally comes from being
able to be honest with each other
because the mission is so important yeah
so that that's a really good point i
actually
it does actually
have to be everybody being bought in on
this so even like trying to get feedback
like when you're growing so fast and you
want to throw things out and just be
like okay let's try this
the company is bound to make some
mistakes i mean it's never like a
straight path to the top you're always
going to hit roadblocks so actually
thinking about your job that way is
something that is important so actually
travis kalanick the ceo of uber or the
founder of uber
he said something that resonated with
with me which is he was like
uh i'm kind of like a math professor
math professors would not be happy if
there weren't any problems like i'm
gonna go through my day and solve
problems so because like inherently
startups are hard work we're upfront
that it's hard work
people can make mistakes and that's fine
as long as we retroactively look at okay
what did we learn as a company let's not
make that mistake again don't take
things personal
uh and since everyone is is trying to
get better like
it's just better and it all comes into
like the growth mindset yeah um what's
been the biggest surprise to you in the
year or so that you've been running the
business obviously it's had you know
meteoric growth uh you're surrounded by
some of the best investors in the world
uh it's obviously a huge problem what's
been the surprises the biggest surprise
is actually when we started the company
the great resignation was happening
there was a huge like everyone was
returning from the pandemic everyone
said oh workers don't want to work no
one can hire
so we actually thought that we would
have a huge like a very big problem on
the supply of workers on the platform
and the demand would come easy
but what actually happened is
workers and a data point to that is
there was 75
more job openings in warehousing than
before the pandemic because everyone
started shopping online distribution
centers were close to where people lived
so and there was just all this pent up
demand so we were like wow the market is
exploding
we're going to have a hard time finding
workers but what we found is now we
actually have so many workers on our
platform we're like we got to get them
more shifts because workers they want to
work they want to return just like how a
lot of people who worked in tech are
like ah i got a flavor of remote i might
want remote people that work in hourly
labor like they have essentially been
handed schedules they're like hey you
have to work these schedules you have to
cover for this person so if you have
child care or anything else you're doing
that this is your this is what you got
to do you got to get paid
also like you usually start with like a
certain shift and you have to earn your
way over a decade to get like a shift
that you want uh
but then workers during the pandemic
also got that flavor like wait a minute
like i am able to have more flexible
work so they're actually returning to
the workforce in droves wanting more
transparency like no one knows what's
happening in a warehouse or what the
conditions of an event are going to be
before you join whereas if you start to
like add a tech layer to it it actually
unlocks a lot for them like for example
and we're we're always thinking about
innovative ways to help them so they're
living paycheck to pay a lot a lot of
them are living paycheck to paycheck
they get paid every two weeks someone
might be like wait that's so like why
would why does why do businesses have to
pay every two weeks well we learned that
there's a certain there's a certain uh
penalty to businesses if they're w2
workers that the business has to pay for
every single paycheck if there's if
there's anything that went wrong so
since we have our legal structure in a
certain way we do instant pay so as a
worker is walking off to the bus stop
they get the money in their bank they're
good to go they can take the bus home so
like we're always thinking about unlocks
but the biggest surprise was the fact
that workers want to work they want to
be upskilled or working on like
completely revolutionizing like the way
that people work in this in this
industry i think a lot about this like
pendulum swing that's happened it's the
last thing i want to spend some time
talking about so during good times uh uh
there's the meme or kind of saying of
like you know good times create weak man
weak men create the bad times and you
kind of have this like cycle that plays
over and over and over again um but what
i do think that we saw over the last
couple of years during the good times uh
was much more receptivity across america
really to uh socialist uh type ideas or
uh this ability of like you know maybe
the government will actually pay me
through ubi or um the popular
popularization of oh wait a minute the
pandemic is happening let's all turn to
the government and they'll send the
stimulus checks they'll bail out certain
industries all this stuff
now that we're heading more towards
tougher economic times and nobody knows
how bad it'll be or how long it'll last
uh it does feel like the pendulum swings
back to hard work no one's coming to
save you like these ideals that
feel like it's what america was built on
talk a little bit about how you think
about operating when you start the
business and frankly good times and now
maybe not going towards such great times
like what changes there or what do you
see in the mindset difference between
the workers that you guys started
working with and maybe the workers today
yeah for sure so
um i'll talk about the customer first
and then i'll talk about us as a
business so
the workers they essentially
workers actually do want to achieve the
american dream they want to work hard
they want to move up in their career i
think a lot of the resentment or like
these socialist like attitudes kind of
sprung up from the fact that a lot of
a lot of uh
industry has not really like unlocked
that to some hourly labor so if you're
working in a warehouse you really can't
become the supervisor unless the
supervisor leaves there's not a lot of
measurement of like how productive you
are whereas
our tech like we're thinking big we're
going to be building all sorts of
productivity tools like uh reaching the
unl where our mission is to unlock the
potential and productivity of workers
and businesses
so it workers on our platform they
actually it is a meritocracy they get
more opportunity for hard work so
we start them out the conditions are
great they they work at a company they
work hard and then with hard work they
get more they get more opportunities so
we do upskilling we are we're paying for
them to get their forklift license if
someone's uh we've had people at event
venues that become supervisors on the
platform to help other to monitor other
workers and essentially make sure that
everyone understands how to use the
technology so
i think that
this socialist mentality also comes from
people in the big cities that are
projecting on to the working class
saying like this is what the working
class wants but the working class like
the working men and women of this
country work extremely hard they have
discipline they wake up early they
they're really pushing
uh and then and then the second one for
us of how we've we've structured the
business so like fortunately for us and
one of the reasons why we were able to
raise such a great round even in this
economic climate and why we're leaning
into growth like we're hiring
aggressively we're almost going to be
tripling our team uh over the next 12
months is because when we started the
company we were very intentional about
we are building something that
businesses and work that really benefits
businesses and workers so our unit
economics are very healthy like we
weren't growing at all costs throwing
money like pretending that our product
was good like we were very intentional
about making sure that we were charging
a healthy market rate to the business uh
workers worked for free on our platform
but we were making sure that we had like
a healthy pay rate for the workers that
they were happy with um so so being
intentional about that actually sets us
up for a lot of success going into a
possible recession because
what happens on the business side is
when times are good you're like okay i
know exactly what's going to happen
spacex is going to put in this order uh
like this company like paramount
pictures is going to buy a bunch of
stuff they do it every year so i'm going
to have 80 full-time staff 20 part-time
like temp labor
now that no one really knows what the
economic climate's going to be is
there's going to be cost-cutting
measures at businesses so
cut the the full-time workforce and then
as they get that oh my gosh i got i got
an order in i've gotta step up like
they're gonna leverage the staffing
industry even more so like we've
actually seen that in customer behavior
where
our type of business actually thrives in
economic downturns and we've really seen
that in what's happening
when
you think out 10 20 years
and somebody comes back and listens to
this
what do you hope to have achieved in
that 10 to 20 year period
i hope that we have made a significant
amount of impact to the way that people
work around the world we we plan on
being a global company
we there's two different verticals of
how we essentially become like the aws
for labor on the workers side like we
are paying we like the money comes from
the business to us we pay the worker
there is so much opportunity for
financial upside and like essentially
being able to help them financially that
we're already looking into we did the
instant pay we're looking into building
a
providing a trauma debit card
we can really uplift the workers in a
lot of different ways there and then on
the business side
we're leaning into automation as well so
like we are our mission to increase the
productivity and potential of workers
and businesses on locks like if you go
into a warehouse today people are still
using walkie-talkies they have these big
scanning guns that are like slapping
amongst them their leg it's huge it was
developed like decades ago
there's so many cool innovations that we
can build that
really unlock like america's workforce
and the world's workforce uh that just
don't exist today and no one's really
working on them right now to close up
what's your pitch to people who are
listening to this like man that sounds
like an awesome company i wonder if they
have any open roles or i wonder whether
it's a job that i could go and work and
enjoy what's your pitch to potential
candidates as to why they should come
work at trava i would say if you're at
the point of your life where you want to
lean into professional growth and trying
to be the best that you can be this is
the place for you we have
like an immense amount of mentorship
from some of the best investors in the
world we are growing significantly fast
which just unlocks a lot of opportunity
to work on really cool innovative
projects we're working on dynamic
pricing uh marketplace tools all this
like really cool stuff uh we're
expanding globally so there's gonna be
opportunities to really
be your own entrepreneur in a different
market and grow that out um the world is
your oyster if you want to work hard and
you want to be like look just like going
to law school like anyone that wants to
go to law school they're like okay i
know it's going to be hard but i'm going
to leave having learned a lot and
meeting the the friends of my lifetime
and that's what we're doing here like
we're in the trenches we're building
together so you're going to have
relationships that last forever kind of
like the traba mafia kind of like the
paypal mafia that's the goal and then
while doing that you're going to have a
very positive impact that you can see in
our customers eyes
while you do it where can people come
find you on the internet or find out
more about travel yeah they can just go
to
www.traba.work like w-o-r-k and we have
a careers page there and you can just
apply there and mention you you listen
to the palm podcast and i'll keep an eye
out for you
if somebody gets a job because they
mentioned that
you'll have to let me know um mike
listen thank you so much for doing this
i'm obviously a huge fan of what you
guys are doing and um it's a huge huge
huge problem uh and i just like the
approach of hey we're gonna find the
best people in the world we're gonna
work our asses off and if everything
goes right we can build you know a
trillion plus dollar company and
actually have a positive impact on these
businesses and workers and i think it's
a mission worth going after so anyone
who hasn't yet uh taken a look go to
trava.work and that will definitely do
this again in the future cool thank you